now we would love to take some questions
from the audience and if I could have
all of our force
speakers join the table your seats are
there and if we have any of the index
cards perhaps some of our volunteers who
are collecting the cards very good we
have some cards heading this way of
course we'd like to invite all of you to
join us as well after the QA for a
reception right outside the atrium so we
hope you join us as well it could be the
speakers and a more of a one-on-one and
you can speak to them more in depth well
thank you very much
oh very good dr. Christakis first
question is how do you determine whether
people are happy or sad can't be very
easy pensive that I thought from Harry
Potter the variety of tools that have
been developed by other scientists
psychologists that measure purport to
measure I think reliably emotional
states and we just use those existing
tools there in that particular study we
had a kind of psychometric scale where
people answered a set of questions and
then they could be grouped into sad and
happy categories some of the other
outcomes I mentioned are a little bit
easier to measure the altruism gain you
actually give people real money and see
whether they give it to other
individuals in the haads other one of
the ways we measured that ties is we
gave people honey honey sticks which the
hosel love and we told them that you
cannot keep this for yourself you must
give it anonymously to other members of
your group and saw what they did so we
have different kinds of objective and
subjective measures for dr. Gianetti did
you ask the patients their preferences
for maintaining function minimizing
symptoms and prolonging life more than
once and if so where their preferences
stable that's a that's an excellent
question and much of that work actually
was dr. Freid who I think had to leave
and the end the answer that is yes as
people change in their health
trajectories very often their
preferences do change over time so so I
think one of one of the things that she
is attempting to do are there particular
traits that do maintain so in general
two people focus on one thing rather
than another but there are also certain
kind of states that ball of preference
that will change as peoples condition
change and it's that's really been shown
very much particularly function is young
and healthy people think if I can't run
a marathon it's not worth living right
and and certainly as people become more
and more ill and more and more
functional what less and less functional
what's important to them does change and
so and that is really certainly one of
the challenges if we're going to use
this in decision making is that is that
as preferences change certainly
decision-making needs a change in that
that certainly is a level of complexity
that we still need to deal with very
good and dr. Strittmatter a question I
have read that only two activities can
slow down Alzheimer's one exercise the
other one is meditation can you comment
on that there may be many many
activities that could slow down
Alzheimer's I guess the question is
which ones have been proven in a
scientifically acceptable sense i think
there's certainly very positive evidence
that both exercise and mental activity
can make a difference whether one type
of activity versus a different is
superior i don't think there's enough
head-to-head evidence to say i recommend
meditation as compared to some other
kind of playing a card game or doing it
working or doing any other kind of
activity so that's not been tested in
the same kind of rigorous way i know
that but i think you know being active
both mentally and physically is
unquestionably beneficial and strongly
to be encouraged absolutely using the
brain function will help slow down
perhaps the process of alzheimer's or
dementia you've seen studies regarding
that i think that certainly would be the
recommendation exactly how much it slows
down and how far we can go with that we
can't say today still have to learn more
about it okay
dr. Chang this person says it's asking
short Telamon telomere causes aging or
cancers how about increasing its length
by technology the lengths of should be
home I just want to make sure that the
length of total telomere it should be
the same length and all cells should
they be the same length in all cells I'm
not sure what technology the writers
referring to but the only way to
increase telomere length and I know of
is through the addition of telomerase so
if you add telomerase to or example stem
cells it will rescue the shortest
telomeres so the shortest telomeres are
the ones that caused the cellular
senescence premature aging phenotypes
but if you have telomerase natural
chilla mirror it's a long gated and then
no longer triggers the DNA damage
response so I think that's the only way
that we know right now to add telomere
length although there are certain
studies that are not you know I don't
necessarily believe it some small
molecules may augment anomalies activity
I think that's that requires a lot of
clinical trials so the lengths of what
about the length of that telomere should
they be all the same length in all the
cells it's only the shortest telomeres
that we worried about so studies have
shown that one short telomeres can
actually initiate the cellular
senescence mechanism so you don't have
to have all your telomeres to be
elongated right you just have to rescue
that one short telomeres I could trigger
the DNA damage response simply said but
difficult to do very different yes ok
dr. Christakis about social contagious
phenomena do you think meet the media or
propaganda have significant effect
introducing and inducing the effect ok
in inducing the effect i would make a
distinction between broadcast mechanisms
and these types of social contagions so
oprah winfrey obviously has much more
power than i do to affect what
will do in this country but she does
that via broadcast mechanisms Oprah
actually probably does not have more
power any more or less power than I do
to affect her personal friends so prob
probably has about as many real friends
as I do and when she recommends a movie
to them or a recipe she probably has
about as much if well maybe not a recipe
but about as much effect as I do so it's
the difference and I'm often asked this
question in the setting of obesity how
can it be that we are gaining weight
even though our ideals about appropriate
bodies have remained relatively constant
and and the answer to that question is
that you are much more affected by what
your friends are doing then you are
affected by what abstract individuals
are doing it's the same thing that leads
prison guards to abuse prisoners they
have the ideal that that we shouldn't do
this but when their peers are abusing
the prisoners they copy them and so this
is a widespread phenomenon so in
socialism both are important the ideal
and the broadcast message are important
but the pure effects are so much more
powerful than the than the Rockets
mechanism okay this is for all of you
how do we increase the likelihood that
policies change as a result of lessons
learned from research dr. Chang
I mean I think I think I think I think
there's a saying I was recently told
that is really stuck with me which is
that you cannot reason a man out of an
opinion he hasn't been reasoned into and
i think that the quality of our public
discourse about science has declined and
i think it's very difficult to use a
reason to persuade people that the kinds
of that that policy should be based on
rational grounds so um and actually many
would argue that's not necessarily
necessary I mean some people would say
what makes you think that evidence
should be the garage a guide to policy
you know maybe the guide to policy
should be some you know god-given ideals
for example or some abstract principles
the truth of course is both because if
you set policy without evidence
eventually you hit reality and the
policy doesn't work but that doesn't
mean principles are unimportant and I
think there was a time in our society I
mean even I can remember it I'm not that
old where we had a more greater respect
for the meaning of evidence in in
formulating policy and how to increase
that I don't know maybe one of my peers
here has some ideas anybody else I guess
I would maybe distinguish between
lessons learned and incorporated by
policy makers or incorporated by society
at large I think there's a huge benefit
towards society at large recognizing
more about the science and the medicine
of aspects of aging the more that the
general population knows about things
that happen as discussed in this kind of
symposium or other forums I think the
more public policy political opinion
will be somewhat more informed I believe
I'm not going to give that up in a
institution of higher learning that the
more we can spread knowledge the more
informed society will be and the more
lessons will translate into policy maybe
that's overly hopeful but I have to
believe that anyway
you well we've seen the impact of people
getting behind the research for breast
cancer because it is such an emotional
issue for families and for women funding
has increased because of this and
because funding has increased research
has moved everything forward for women
and so perhaps with the aging issue that
if we aren't people with more
information that they'll get behind this
as more of us live longer especially
when it comes to Alzheimer's we're
saying one case comes up every seven
seconds that should be something that we
should all be concerned about well I
think there's growing concern awareness
of frequently reported you know on the
front pages of newspapers it's gaining
more and awareness I think what what may
not have reached the general public is
the idea that science may be the
solution to the problems that we're all
kind of beginning to recognize more and
more that the aging population and
Alzheimer's disease are a growing
problem a massive problem what's our way
out of it maybe science is the way out
of it maybe the niña maybe the finding
out more and discovering more is our
only solution well we need more money
though to do that right well I think
that I mean we also need wisdom and good
experiments and and wise use of of them
the funding exactly a money problem but
of course that matters absolutely
anybody else would like to jump in on
that I think just you know I think your
question about this the aging and people
people recognize it is the most
important health condition in this
country people rally emotionally around
individual diseases such as breast
cancer it's a very good example in fact
we had grand rounds this morning showing
that the potential downside consequences
of the being emotionally driven approach
that that if anything in breast cancer
researchers are very important but it's
the the proportion of resources that go
into breast cancer really are out of
proportion somewhat 22 and it's um not
necessarily at the expense because it's
not a zero-sum game but there are
certain conditions that are easier to
rally emotions around and I think a lot
of this is emotion driven and and
certainly those of us at aging have
really tried to do exactly what you've
talked about is trying to get people to
be aware and to focus and put some
resources into understanding aging is in
its in its been complex I mean we've a
lot of good minds have tried to do and I
think it's an important thing but it it
has I think we haven't yet gotten there
in terms of how to resonate resonated
wait we should dr. tinetti this question
is for you my mother is on 12 different
medications can I do anything now to
help what can we do for her well I think
the that the most important thing is to
have a good discussion with a doctor and
unfortunately she's on 12 medicine she
probably has five or six doctors as well
but the most important thing is to find
out from her mother what's most
important thing to her and then to talk
to her doctor and saying this is what's
important to my mother which of these
medications are most likely to help and
are any of them hurting for what's most
important to her and that's that's
really as good as we can do right now
because we really don't have the
research and the evidence to say for
each individual person this is
definitely what's right for you this is
definitely what's right for you but I
think at least we can start that
dialogue of at least heightening
everybody's awareness of this medication
is it going to influence the outcome
that's most important to me and that's
the dialogue that we should be having
increasingly with our physicians so the
person who has his mother needs to talk
to all her physicians perhaps because
the mom may not be able to do so right
or or even more importantly what we
advocate is is that this person and her
mother identified who is who should be
the primary physician making the
decision and and really and make it
clear to the network of physicians to
use
two classes where is that there is a
network of physicians is really identify
one of them who is the decision maker
and really feed all and rather than
seven doctors making making suggestions
as they all should make the suggestion
to the one doctor who weighs all of it
that's that's the ideal world it's not
the way medicine practices but it's it's
the direction we're trying to again
we're talking about patient-centered
care here patient-centered care we all
agree on it who can disagree with it
right it's like apple pie but how do you
make it happen okay dr. Christakis can
your network analysis distinguished
benefits of connections between ages you
mean inter-gender mixed-gender it says
gently I'll go on here it says evolution
tells us often reproduction we said
correct we are no longer useful we are
no longer useful but many of us
appreciate the wisdom of our elders I
see actually we we I have just two two
things to say about that first is a very
trivial observation that humans if
events homophily on age that is to say
young people hang out with young people
and older people with other people and
this is like anything else that humans
do so there is H segregation within
these social fabrics that's not too
surprising and there's another body of
work which is not our work other people
have done work on the benefits of
grandparents in fact one of the theories
as to why why we live so long
evolutionary biologists are taking this
increasingly seriously is that actually
the exhibit the our survival after we
reproduce and our own children reach
adulthood beyond that is precisely
because it confers fitness advantages to
the next generation and this you know in
modern setting this could be include
everything from wealth transmission to
wisdom transmission and so forth and you
actually you see this in elephants too
which is very interesting elderly
elephants herds that are led by older
elephants fare much better in times of
drought than herds that are led by
younger matriarchs so there's a lot of
convergent evolution evidence from
evolutionary biology that helps shed
light on why what the role of age at
individuals with
the population is and helps to explain
why there's some particularly long-lived
species where it's hard on first
principles to understand why what would
be the benefit to living to be 70
incidentally even even honza God either
the survival was much shorter in bygone
era but that was primarily due to infant
mortality conditional and surviving 25
years we have lengthened survival in
humans over the last hundred years but
not as much as as you would think and we
have one last question is that right
okay and this will be the dr. Chang I'm
on oh it is dr. Christakis okay well let
me ask dr. change this question really
good he'll aware of a change the
telomeres studies you've conducted been
in animal studies when will it go to the
human side I think that's the
million-dollar question with more
support from than I I think yeah I think
the first telomerase therapy will
probably be conducted on patients with
this characteristic in general patients
with a clear need for telomerase
addition and you know trials on cells
now have shown that if you add
telomerase to patients with cells or
patient with this characters congenita
it restores telomere length so it's
possible that these stem cells could be
transfused back to these patients and
you know they may be cured of this
potential disease now hopefully in the
future we could maybe use telomerase
therapy to engineer stem cells to
perhaps in terms of regenerative
medicine to maybe make artificial organs
and things like that that we could you
know replace aging organs in that
particular fashion maybe that will
circumvent the cancer problem that's
always just you know flip side of this
you see clinical trials starting soon
human critical clinical trials there
have been so there are trials against
Columbus so this anti Thomas therapy
have
in clinical chosen these are anti-cancer
Peppa therapy using specific
oligonucleotide against jalama Ruiz and
some of these clinical trials have
failed because they have been proven to
be too toxics obviously patient stem
cells have been compromised so as to
whether you could be stored telomerase
in as an anti-aging therapeutic that has
not been attempted yet very good all
right so our last question did eyes are
very optimistic wrist I just have to say
as questions reflect the level of loft
with this phenomenal could you say more
about how you identify a central person
for intervention targeting so i use the
centrality the individuals as an
illustration it actually turns out that
you wouldn't necessarily want to use
central people but it's a very visually
easy concept to to show and actually our
algorithms don't necessarily emphasize
central people but it is mathematically
not difficult to identify central people
and and basically central people are
people whose friends are more central
not that may sound like the tail you
know the snake eating its own tail but
actually you can work out that math and
you can find individuals who are not
only who are not only have many friends
but whose friends have many friends and
that's in a sense one of the definitions
of centrality the other definition is is
that central people are more paths
through the network of all the paths you
could define and you can define all the
past there's a finite set through any
network a central person will have more
of those paths go through them so you
can use this math to it to identify very
good thank you very much and thank you
for being here they did a terrific job
in bed
you